غضب وحداد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس فالاضراب العام
شل مناحي الحياه كافه وازداد الغضب بعد
كشف مزيد من وقائع ومشاهد المجزره التي
ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال من بينها هذه
الصور التي التقطتها كاميرات مراقبه من
احد المحال التجاريه وتظهر وحده مستعربين
تخفوا بملابس نساء ورجال بعضهم ارتدى
ملابس الصلاه والنقاب واخفوا الاسلحه
الحديثه في سجادات الصلاه اللي صار في
مدينه جدا احنا
منا اليوم
نعبر عن غضبنا
صار في مدينه نابلس يعني هذا اقل واجب انه
احنا نسويه يعني اللي بيصير في نابلس
بيصير في القدس
جنازات الشهداء تتواصل ففي نابلس شيع موس
استشهد بعد اصابته في المجزره اما في جنين
فشيع الفلسطينيون مقاوما من كتيبه جنين
استشهد متاثرا باصابته بجراح قبل اسبوعين
الجنازه تحولت الى مسيره غضب حدادا على
ارواح شهداء مجزره نابلس
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه دفعت القياده
الفلسطينيه الى العوده مجددا لمجلس الامن
الدولي معتبره ان حكومه الاحتلال نصفت
التفاهمات التي تم التوصل اليها بوساطه
امريكيه من الواضح ان اليمين الاسرائيلي
المتطرف امثال بنجافير وسمتريتش يواصلون
تنفيذ جرائمهم بهدف تفجير ساحه الصراع
وبالتالي كان لابد لنا من التوجه مره اخرى
لمجلس الامن الدولي
ووفقا لوزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان بدايه
هذا العام هي الاكثر الدمويه في الضفه
الغربيه منذ عام 2000 اكثر من 63 شهيدا
سقطوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال في اقل من
شهرين مشهد دفع الفلسطينيين للمطالبه
مجددا بتوحيد الصف الداخلي لمواجهه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي رفعت
درجه التاهب لكنها ايضا برايهم تخطط كله
الخطوط الحمراء
الجزيره رام الله